good afternoon
vaccines are at the heart of a
government strategy to manage covid19
as of today 18 million 242
873 people
have been vaccinated across the united
kingdom and
18 million 911
978 doses have been given
overall since yesterday 9
938 people are reported to have tested
positive for coronavirus
as of the 22nd of february 2021
16 803 people were in hospital with
coronavirus
that's down 20 percent from the week
before
and sadly of those who have tested
positive for coronavirus
across all settings 121
747 are reported to have now
died that's an increase of 442
fatalities since yesterday
and our thoughts are very much with the
families of those who have
lost loved ones to this virus
on monday the prime minister outlined
the road map
out of lockdown and gave us the news
that we've all been waiting for
we can now plan for the return of all
pupils to schools and colleges
as part of a roadmap for leaving
lockdown
i want to say once again a massive thank
you to our incredible teachers
leaders support staff and child care
workers
you have been going above and beyond
to keep schools and colleges open for
vulnerable children and children of
critical workers
and to keep the remainder of young
people learning
when they're at home i also want to
thank
parents who've been supporting their
children while they learn at home
and i want to thank children and young
people themselves for their patience and
resilience
i know it hasn't been easy but you have
adapted and done
so much to make sure that you've been
able to continue to learn
everyone everyone is longing
for a return to normality and i want you
to know that
we're continuing to support schools
colleges and teachers with extra help
to boost children's learning we're
investing in a range of options that
parents and children will benefit from
whether that's summer schools extra
funding for specialist teaching and
expanding our national tutoring program
as the prime minister said we can now
take the next steps
these will be cautious but that's
crucial
if we don't want to end up going
backwards
so the process we've planned will be
carefully managed
at every stage i'm incredibly pleased
that the latest data tells us that we
are able to proceed with a full return
of schools and colleges
from monday the 8th of march
as we outlined earlier this week primary
school pupils return to school
on that day while secondary schools and
colleges will be able to stagger their
return
over that week to ensure all their
students can be offered
covered tests wrap around child care
for primary and secondary school pupils
will also resume from the 8th of march
university students who are studying
practical courses
who need specialist facilities can also
return to campus
from then on too we'll review the timing
for return of the remaining students by
the end of easter holidays
despite everyone's best efforts
many children are going to need longer
term support if they're to make the
educa
educational progress that they need
this is why the prime minister and
myself appointed our education recovery
commissioner sir kevin collins
to advise on how our early year settings
as well as our schools and colleges
can address these learning gaps as
quickly and as comprehensively as
possible
but because young people just cannot
afford to wait
we're putting in place a range of
immediate measures for schools to start
now
to recover lost learning today we're
announcing the introduction of a new
one-off 302
million pound recovery premium for state
primary
and secondary schools building on the
pupil premium
to further support pupils who need it
most
we're expanding our successful tutoring
programs
200 million pounds will fund an extended
national tutoring program for primary
and secondary schools
an extension to the 16 to 19 tuition
fund
to support more students in english
maths and other vocational
and academic subjects and funding to
support
language development in early years
children
finally 200 million pounds will be
available
for secondary schools to deliver
face-to-face summer schools
schools will be able to target
individual pupils needs
this means that if your child needs
extra help
then they will able to get it for
example
a block of tutoring can help a child
gain three to five months of catch up
when learning
we know our teachers are best placed to
understand what your children will need
so they'll have the tools to deliver
that
extra boost and make a real difference
as we recover from this pandemic
the package announced today will build
on the one billion pound catch-up
package we announced last june
and forms part of a wider response to
help pupils make up for
the lost learning they've suffered
this isn't just about more money for
schools
this is investing in our children this
boost to learning
will be assessed and evidence based and
will track the outcomes
the scientific advice does support a
full return for schools on the 8th of
march
as professor chris witte said on monday
the risk to children is incredibly low
from going to school
and from catching covid so everything is
strongly in favor
of children going to school
we are supporting this return with a
robust testing regime
they'll be critical in breaking the
chains of
covid infection four million
tests have already been completed across
primary secondary schools
and colleges staff have
worked hard to set up testing sites in
schools
and have had time to get used to
supervising for testing
we're now expanding asymptomatic testing
further
and have published full details online
in line with public health guidance
we're also now advising that face
coverings should be worn in secondary
school classrooms
as well as in further and higher
education settings
unless social distancing can be
maintained
again this is to help reduce
transmission
the risk to children themselves is
incredibly low
this is a temporary measure to support
the safe return of schools
and will be in place until easter when
it's reviewed
all the other safety measures that are
already in place continue to be robust
including bubble groups staggered starts
and staggered finishes
increasing ventilation and strict
hygiene measures
return to school is what we have been
looking forward to
it is time for children to be back in
school learning and playing with their
friends
but we must also look to the future no
child should have their prospects
blighted by the pandemic and i'm
determined that this
isn't going to happen tomorrow we'll be
setting out for details on how grades
will be
awarded this summer while i cannot
preempt that announcement
i'm very pleased to say that it will
confirm that this year
we're putting our trust firmly in the
hands of teachers
the broad range of catch-up measures we
have planned will enable children to
start recouping
not just for lost learning time but the
fun
and friendship that they have missed out
so much
on they quite simply deserve no less
i think our whole nation has never
before
valued what schools and teachers and
education bring to all of our children
more than it does today
and i think we'll all be so much willing
for the successful return of all our
children back into school
on the 8th of march
now we're going to have the opportunity
to turn to
mark from yorkshire who's got the first
question
hello if decisions are driven by the
data and the data is better than
expected
will the roadmap out of lockdown be
accelerated thank you
well as the prime minister said that
there are no plans whatsoever to
be moving ahead of the dates that have
already been given
we want to give public as well as
business
the confidence and the assurance as to
when these next steps are going to be
happening uh but there are certainly no
plans to be
uh moving ahead of that uh jenny i'm not
sure if there's anything you wanted to
add probably just to reinforce the fact
that the
the timelines have been set for very
good public health reasons we need to be
able to see
the change in the infection rates the
development of illness the effect of the
vaccine and the effect on
hospitalizations in the nhs
and all of that takes a time and it
usually takes a week or 10 days or so
for a particular intervention to embed
so one of the positive things from my
perspective from the school
starting back is we have a a really good
clear window now to see
uh to make sure that what we expect to
happen does actually happen and then
review so i think
certainly we we will be looking to keep
those timelines as much as we can
and next we turn to lauren from
tonbridge
hello with the new roadmap for reopening
the country it was mentioned that all
legal limits on social contact will be
removed by the 21st of june of the
earliest
does this include the use of mass and
ppe indoors
if not how long do you think this rule
will apply
jenny if i can turn to you um so i think
i go back to the the points that we've
just made about being really clear
about the impact that different
interventions have and these lifting of
measures as we go forward
one of the things we know of course is
that doing things outside is ever so
much
safer than doing things inside
ventilation we know is really important
and fresh air is
always reduces if you like the density
of the virus
so outdoors is not so much of an issue
and you'll see that coming through
in the the guidance and the road map i
think
we have to look at these different
interventions and look at the data as
the roadmap says
and check where we are and i think
as i think sir patrick said earlier this
week that as we get into the autumn
when winter comes in and we spend more
time inside then again we may be looking
at it but it's quite possible
over summer months as we did last year
when we see rates drop
that we would not need to be wearing uh
masks all that time
and obviously ppe uh ppe
ppe actually is is very much for um
clinical use face coverings clearly is
for
general use so i think summer period is
generally we think is a much safer
period for us
with less need for interventions but i
think that doesn't rule it out as we go
into winter periods again and and as the
secretary of state has said and the
roadmap sets out
we have to stick very much to looking at
the evidence and then acting on that as
we go forward
next we turn to branwyn jeffries from
the bbc
brownwood education secretary you've
provided
short-term cash today but when will you
have
a long-term plan to help children
recover
and you've said just now that if your
child
needs help they will get it is that a
promise
that parents can hold you to
so branwyn what we all want to see is we
want to see all of our children back
into schools we know that schools are
the very best place for
all of our children and as part of this
700
million pound package that we are
rolling out building on the billion
pounds that we announced last year
we're giving schools the tools that they
need in order to be able to deliver
for all children in that schools
but it is it is a real sense and a real
belief that we can help
all children within the education system
this is why we've taken such a broad
range of measures
but given schools for flexibility in
order to be able to
sort of make sure that it's properly
targeted to the children who need the
most help
and in terms of when further details
about the
more mid-term and long-term reforms that
we'll be seeing
as you'll be well aware we just pointed
to
kevin collins uh just a couple of weeks
ago
we want to give kevin a little bit of
opportunity and we're already doing
an extensive amount of work in terms of
engaging with
schools teachers parents and children
themselves
in terms of looking at what are the next
steps to best be able to boost their
education
and actually come out of this pandemic
stronger
bolder being able to deliver a better
and stronger education system for every
single one of our children
uh branwyn do you have another question
just to follow up on that that point you
seem to be promising every parent that
if their child needs help
they will get it is that a promise they
can hold you too
well schools have always delivered for
all children right across the country
and the reason that we've given such a
broad range of tools for schools to be
able to
bring to bear to help children whether
it is for summer schools
whether it's for targeted tuition or
whether it's for flexibility with the
extra 302 million
pounds that will be going into school
budget to be able to craft that to the
specific needs
we'd hoped that that would be able to
meet the needs of all children
whatever their background in terms of
being able to help them catch up so yes
we're very much supporting all children
in our whole school system
next if we move to dan hewitt at
itv dan thank you education secretary
and two questions
um i'm happy if you don't answer them
yes or no if you want
um are school days going to be extended
to help up with the catch-up program
and are summer holidays or could summer
holidays be cut short this summer
to help children catch up so on um
on summer holidays what we've done in
terms of the 200 million pound program
is we're wanting schools to be putting
on
great activities whether it's educat
education led or
even sort of well-being led so we'd be
hoping that schools can be
offering that draw down that funding in
order to be offering that to children
children so yes we would hope that
schools are offering
time in schools for children
and that's why we've put for funding
there in terms of
you ask about lengthening for school
days as part of
this plan it's not a part of a plan in
terms of lengthening school days
but as i've touched on in the past what
we're wanting to do is
wanting to see a real change a step
change in what we can deliver in terms
of our schools
that's why we're taking this in-depth
look at
how do we drive results how do we drive
attainment how do we drive the
the chances of youngsters from the most
disadvantaged backgrounds
and that's why we've asked kevin to do
this extensive look
at education and what reforms what
changes we can bring about
uh dan i'm not sure if there's a
follow-up question
uh yeah well you mentioned exams earlier
so i'll ask about that can we
assume then that it's going to be full
teacher assessment on exam results this
year no
no algorithms and how will the appeal
process work in that case
uh well as i've uh said many times
before we're putting our trust in
teachers
that's wherever trust is going there's
going to be no algorithms whatsoever
but there will be a very clear and
robust appeals mechanism
but i'm afraid you're going to have to
forgive me uh it's right that this is
announced to the house of commons
and uh not to yourself so sorry about
that dan but that will be happening
tomorrow so
just a few more hours to wait um
next if we can turn to ben at uh lbc
ben thank you secretary of state no
doubt at all that children have missed
out on a huge amount of school but
they've also missed
out on a huge amount of other elements
of normal life so secretary said
can you reassure them today and
guarantee that the government will
not allow a situation this summer
whereby children
young people others who may have not
been vaccinated yet
will be prevented from going to the
cinema going out for me or going on
holiday
with their family and if i could ask dr
harris there's some
evidence that the so-called kent variant
infects people for longer than the
original strain 13
days for the kent variant one study
found compared to eight for the original
covert strain
they say the authors of that study that
means that the 10-day quarantine period
may need to be lengthened
is that something you're looking at and
if that did happen
is it your view that more would need to
be done to support people financially
to quarantine when they need to do so
thank you
jenny would you like to go for this
thank you for that so yes um
obviously we look at the different
variants uh regularly
we have variants of interest and
variance under of concern
those are being monitored you'll be
aware that the uk has
probably the best genomics functionality
in the world and we're contributing
actually to world science on that so
absolutely watched all the time
it different studies will come out with
slightly different uh
periods and what you will have seen with
the original
if you like the original coronavirus in
the uk is that we
manage the length of time for quarantine
to minimize the inconvenience to
individuals but still
reduce the risk of onward infection and
so yes we are looking at this but i
think we need to be really careful just
because
as with the original coronavirus you can
still
the time that you detect the virus
doesn't mean necessarily that that is
the infectious period
it may be different in others and of
course at the moment we are
vaccinating really brilliantly across
the country um
and so we have quite a different mix at
the moment of uh transmission risks
who may be at risk so we're just
starting to see early signs that
those most vulnerable uh will have uh
less chance of serious
disease um and and we will have to adapt
that as we go through but
actually every variant will be looked at
if it is a significant
uh of transmission risk across the uk
and ben
picking up on the question that you
asked me uh i think as a
a dad myself with uh two daughters i
i think uh the the novelty of going for
walks with me
is starting to run a bit thin now and
they want sort of a
slightly more enhanced entertainment uh
so i i think from uh
as a dad's point of view i'm very
desperate to make sure that they're able
to
uh enjoy the benefits of opening up
society opening up different parts of
the economy
and being able to get out there so i'm
absolutely
sure we're not going to be
disadvantaging our young people
to be able to enjoy the benefits of
stepping out into the world so much more
than they've been able to
ben i'm not sure if you've got another
question uh
please don't feel obliged if you have if
you haven't
there was just a quick thing relating to
what you said earlier say
obviously you're leaving the summer
schools question to individual schools
how are you going to make sure that the
inequalities in education that we've
seen
worse than in this period don't worsen
still
by lack of central coordination over
that catch-up program
well we we're really sort of driving for
sort of tempo
giving the schools resources our
regional schools commissioners will be
working very closely with local
authorities
multi-academy trusts and individual
schools themselves in order to be able
to ensure that we have this
level and you know schools are meeting
our expectations in terms of spending
this money
on uh interventions that are really
going to help
children and it's something that's
already ofsted
started to be able to look at and assess
and actually giving
schools guidance as to how best to be
able to
to go forward with this investment that
we're making in them and of course the
brilliant work of the education
endowment foundation
giving very clear guidance about how
best we can help
but this is part of a reason why we did
the national tutoring program as well
ben
because there's so much evidence based
around the fact that
it really does drive attainment with
children
almost more than any other single
intervention
and this is a resource that's available
to all schools around the country
we want to see them making use of it
it's going to be truly transformational
for the lives of hundreds of thousands
next if we can uh move to camilla
uh turner from the telegraph camilla
thank you and to our education secretary
um
william hague said that the impact of
covert on children will leave the
biggest scar
of the pandemic and require a revolution
in teaching
but how revolutionary are you prepared
to be would you consider things like
smaller class sizes
building more schools and longer terms
and secondly
do you believe the covert generations
life chances
are as good as those from other
generations and to the deputy chief
medical officer
much has been said about the damage to
children's education
but what assessment has been made of the
damage to their wider development
by not being able to play with their
friends or see their grandparents
so camilla if i i take the two questions
that you sort of pose me and then hand
over to jenny
um we do need to see um we always need
to have children at the heart of
everything that we do
uh every intervention every change that
we make to our schooling system it's got
to be focused on one thing
and that's driving change and
improvement in terms of the outcomes
that children are going to have
and that's what we've tasked sir kevin
to do and there's a number
uh of areas that we need to be looking
at and it is for
you know one of those is making sure
that we're always
driving up the quality of teaching
making sure that
children are getting the very best uh
teaching in the classroom
also the second item is looking at the
time
that children are spent actually
learning
uh having the benefit of being able to
pick up knowledge
and the third element is making sure
that we're targeting
uh children in the best possible way
making sure that those children that
need those interventions
that we're delivering on that it would
be wrong of me to try and preempt what
sir kevin is going to come forward with
but there is
a real appetite and a desire to make
sure we deliver the absolute
most for every single one of our
children but that's going to be based on
evidence of what works and
what works is going to be what drives us
in terms of
reforms and changes that we need to
deliver for all our changes
and i coming on to your second point
about the life chances of this
covid uh you know children who have been
at school
during this period of um this covered
pandemic
now as someone who has two daughters at
school
i'm absolutely certain that we are going
to do
everything we can do for all of our
children to make sure that they do not
uh they're not set back by this pandemic
that their life chances are in
any way not stinted we're going to do
everything we can do to make sure that
they can reach our absolute potential
this is why we're willing to look at
every single matter in order to be able
to drive their attainment
into the future and we are not going to
be timid
in terms of you know our aspirations for
them
and the actions that we'll have to take
to deliver for them
um jenny if thank you section of state
um yes so i think in the same way that
face-to-face education we know that
missing that
has really significant negative impacts
on
children's cognitive emotional academic
wellbeing and
on their physical and mental health and
i think it's not although we naturally
think of grandparents there are many
families with entirely different makeups
where there are significant other
individuals
who children attach to and learn from
and are really important in their lives
that they haven't been able to see
sage so the scientific advisory group on
emergencies has looked
particularly particularly the
face-to-face children's education
risks around that but generally as well
about children's well-being
and we know that mental health has
deteriorated for many children it was
rates of referrals for children's mental
health had increased anyway in recent
years but certainly
it has increased again during the
pandemic which of course is why it's so
important that children do go back to
school
the only caveat i would just say at the
moment around
you know wanting to go and see your
grandparents which is absolutely natural
is two things one the testing program in
schools is clearly going to mean
that people parents grandparents and
teachers and other school children can
be
very assured that schools will be as
safe as they can because we are
trying to remove infection from that
environment and of course that will have
a really positive impact
on breaking change of transmission in
communities
and in those families but the slight
caveat to that is having got so far down
the line with this and now uh on the
road matt very very carefully coming out
uh i would encourage children not to go
off yet even if their grandparents have
had their vaccinations
not to go hugging them too much until
we're absolutely sure
what the impact of that vaccine rollout
has been i'm sure it's going to be
positive but we just need to
take a steady course out through the
roadmap camila i know you managed to get
three questions into your first
question but i wasn't sure if you just
got one very one
uh very short one uh to sort of follow
up
um yeah so if we we know that children's
education has been massively disrupted
and also their mental
health has um taken a huge hit in the
past year
um for the education secretary do you
acknowledge that the government's
policies over the past year have played
a role in this deterioration of
children's mental health conditions as
well as their academic learning loss
well what the government has done is one
of uh you know we've got one of the most
impressive vaccine
roles out of any major industrial
country anywhere in the world
by taking the uh the big decisions that
the prime minister had to take
early last year when many people were
saying they weren't necessary this has
actually created a very clear pathway
as how we rebound out of this and of
course
as you all know camilla i always want to
see children
in schools all the time because you know
i see the values that they get i see the
pleasure that they get
but we know that there are there have
been
um you know children not being in school
uh is something that we never want to
see and obviously children
um do lose out as a result of that and
that's why we've got the
you know a 700 million pound package
today in terms of
rolling out to schools to support them
and we're looking
at very much solutions that support a
child and help a child
really succeed in the future and that's
the work that we're currently
undertaking and we're certainly going to
deliver on
next if i can go to will hazel at vi
will
nate uh my first question is on the
twice weekly home cover testing
which secondary school people how are
you actually going to make sure
that they do that and would you like to
take this opportunity
for to ask parents
to check that they're doing that each
week and then secondly
on summer schools who's actually going
to start these
classes over the holidays and would you
like
to see teachers actually take some time
out of their holidays to help run those
well on the second point in terms of
summer schools the reason that we've
given
schools the additional resource
is that they're then in a position to be
able to
pay existing staff bring new staff in uh
be able to properly
uh resource these schools and give a
sort of high
quality um support for for children that
come in there so
it's really about the flexibility of
what works for the school
but most importantly what will be
working best for the children within
that school
if that school decides to draw down on
that funding
and in terms of a twice weekly testing
yes i very much would hope that
parents would be there to support for
children in doing this
we're seeing over the first two weeks of
schools return
we'll be seeing in that first two weeks
children doing the tests but being
supervised
as part of that so they properly learned
the process
about how to do it and but that's
you know following on from that that
twice weekly testing regime
i certainly hope that parents will be
encouraging and supporting
children in doing that but we're also
asking
schools to keep open a asymptomatic
testing center so if children haven't
been able to get the support or the help
that maybe they need
to do the test at home is possible to do
the test in school as well
um i'm not sure if anything on testing
and just to add to that i think the the
way that nhs test and tracer set this up
it is important that those
tests are reported back um and for 18
year olds and above
uh that's obviously an independent um uh
process
for 12 to 17 year olds as the secretary
of state has said then uh
that is an adult overseen process but i
think it's really
important people understand these are
very very simple things to do many of
the public are doing this now if they
perhaps go into work or
if they're a healthcare worker and in
fact what's being
set up for schools and for staff in
schools is very similar to what happens
for healthcare workers so i think staff
can be particularly assured
that that same sort of testing spacing
and approach
is there for them and for their pupils
so i think inherently
safer environments in schools as we go
forward with the with this additional
uh testing mechanism and at will to add
we've obviously seen
uh testing uh rolled out since january
across uh
education settings it's been taken up uh
with enormous
enthusiasm we've also seen the role out
of home testing in terms of workforce
and the reporting back on this has been
incredibly positive with
you know one of the highest rates of
return of any workplace setting
uh being within schools so uh
via all the initial indications are uh
it's been an enthusiastic embracing uh
of uh self-testing and we look forward
to seeing that expanded further
uh will i'm not sure if you've got a a
quick follow-up question or if there's
anything else
just just the quick i may um it's
for uh secondary school pupils to wear
classroom
in august boris johnson's children
wearing masks
in classes was nonsensical and that you
can't expect to learn with face
coverings
i'm just wondering uh if you agree with
them so
we've always said well all the way
through this is that we'll always follow
the best scientific
medical and health advice and when we
uh have that uh advice come forward
that's obviously
uh quite rightly for the advice that we
follow uh
jenny i'm not sure if there's anything
you want to say on the wearing face
i will actually because i think for uh
earlier on in the uh broadcast when
i was talking to lauren i was speaking
very general terms and obviously this is
very
about face coverings and their use so i
think we need to be very clear about
face masks and ppe which is for
clinical use obviously face coverings
are there to
help others we're protecting others by
wearing them and there are a number of
different conditions at the moment
so for example we have a new variant and
while we are understanding that more
um then obviously taking additional
precautions uh
makes sense we understand more about the
um
ability for aerosol generation and
transmission
so that is also important so things i
think have moved on and
it should be reassuring to know that we
look at the evidence and then
adjust our advice accordingly but i
think also one of the
things here if testing is coming into
place in schools
and we we will see but it's very likely
that we will find a few cases and there
will be
some children do have to stay at home
unfortunately for a short period at the
start of term
but then over time what will happen is
those
school environments should be free more
or less free of infection
and at that point as the secretary of
state has said previously around easter
time then obviously that is another
issue
to consider it is important many
children
can't communicate well particularly
small children which is why this hasn't
been
suggested for primary schools and and
really important to understand that any
child
or any uh adult or other people helping
them
who who needs to be able to be seen
to communicate effectively then there
are exemptions for this just as there
are uh for our general uh use of face
coverings in public
thank you well uh next and finally we
move on to
amy gibbons from the times educational
supplement
thank you education secretary are you
worried that teachers faith
in your department has plummeted to the
point where 96
lack trust in your handling of the
pandemic
well amy thanks ever so much for coming
to ask a question what we're focused on
is making sure that all children are
back into school at the
the right time and the best possible
moment that's going to be the 8th of
march
we know that children benefit most of
all from being in school
we know that our children need to be in
school in terms of not just their
education but their mental health and
their
their their development and that is why
our focus is making sure
that they are back in school on the 8th
of march and it's something that i know
so many teachers are also very keen to
see because
they want to be welcoming their children
as well
well i'd like to take the opportunity to
say thank you everyone for
tuning in and thank you for all you're
doing to make sure
everyone in the nation is safe thank you